i i i can't help it i don't know what to
do i'm just the bug is real nick
but on the flip side they're gonna
they're gonna make more money than
they've ever seen in their life
i'm literally gonna make more money in
sports cards this year that i made in
vaynermedia the last 10 years it's like
absurd
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
welcome nick hi nick this is gonna be
awfully difficult because uh
you and i have been completely uh
addicted to sports cards together
over like i've been sprinkling it in i'm
so addicted i'm sure andre is like
why is gary doing him he's usually
pretty weird but this is like take next
level
i literally want to take all 20 minutes
and just talk to you about vintage
basketball and prism and zion's
but let's first talk about you know you
joined
tick-tock when again april 20th
right like like how is it
transitioning you know for everybody
right a lot of people are about to get
new jobs
people are starting to get new jobs
right now being
respectful of the audience and trying to
bring the most value what was the
biggest challenge and what's been the
biggest gift
of joining a new org in the middle of
the pandemic
yeah i'll start with the biggest gift uh
all that
awkwardness where you get to the office
and you're like where do i sit
who do i have lunch with what do i do
where's the coffee where's that and you
don't worry about that at all
so like getting that out of the way it's
been easy to just work from home and
then get to meet people through
zoom and on meetings and just get to
know them as people before you're like
worried about you know
where everything is in the office i'd
say on the flip side
all those casual conversations that you
have that are unplanned and spontaneous
you know we're not having that at this
time so it is a little bit more
difficult you have to plan these uh
encounters
a little bit more hopefully with the
team even if it's like a five minute
check in here or there
or i have uh office hours where people
can just like
um zoom me uh during that time just to
make sure that they get some face time
to try to recreate those spontaneous
moments the other random thing that i
did for my team
um that i think was fun is uh when
you're in this environment
you're not networking outside of your
team you basically see your team
every day every meeting each week
and you're not getting access to people
outside so i've been inviting
special guests into the team meeting so
that they can meet either influencers or
artists or people that they admire
outside and i even ask them to give me
requests on
who they want to talk to next and it's
surprising because it'll range from
a celebrity or a music artist to like an
actual business leader that runs brand
for another company so
bringing people into the mix and getting
them to you know network outside of the
team has been
pretty fun what uh what most surprised
you about tick tock
you're obviously you've had a
skyrocketing career
you know you've been in all sorts of
incredible brands
um and so for me
you're not coming into this role not
knowing tic toc
you probably come into this role knowing
tick tock way better than most
people in corporate land you came you
were at hulu prior
taco bell like you you know i admire you
tremendously so
what what did surprise you though when
you know no matter what you know when
you get under the hood
it becomes different what uh what's what
stood out
this is gonna sound like
uh set up but it's not at all um i came
in the midst of
the pandemic and uh black lives matter
protests
and to see the amount of empathy
from the leadership down on
not only like what is happening with the
business because they actually didn't
worry about that as much as they cared
about
what are we doing to help uh voices be
heard and shared what are we doing to
help
covet relief efforts um how are we
deploying funds
in terrible countries like the thing
that we did with you yeah
like that was a big initiative for the
company not because
of users i don't know if my team i don't
know if my team reached out to you but
um
uh my team in london is working with
unicef and
this morning i confirmed that i'm gonna
do something i think on monday
yeah i'm coming back to the platform not
for 12 hours that was [ __ ] insane
but i'm going on for two hours i think
yeah but that's that's the stuff that i
didn't expect coming into the hood like
i thought it was just a
you know platform and that your
marketing platform but coming in they
really want to just do
good in the world and help others in a
meaningful way and provide impact so
that's why when
we're talking to you and we threw out
the idea of like hey let's raise money
for meals on wheels and no kid hungry
it was like a no-brainer they're like
yes absolutely how can we support and
how can we contribute and how do we make
this a bigger thing to help support
things that are
important for us so i've been able to
see that side of uh
tick tock which i don't think most
people get to see which has been pretty
dope
is it challenging being on some a brand
a platform
that obviously has the dynamic of being
china owned in a highly political kind
of environment
like i you know i because you know i
always advocate where there's
underpriced attention and every single
person watching here
not because of nick because like i said
earlier i'm only buying him one oreo i
don't care that much not because
i own zero of bite dance and tic toc
even though that gets thrown around
every day
like you know it's just because i think
the platform is extremely right
um so when people you know as soon as
any tick tocks in the news i get like
i get moral i basically get two massive
alerts right now either a
something's going on with tick tock and
i've got to answer for it because like
i'm like the pied piper or two some
sports car just went up four times and
people are trying to figure out if i
like talked about it like you know both
intersect in your world
you know uh is that challenging a little
bit though like when people are just
spreading
non-troops and it's like or like you
know just like like has that been
daunting or not really
uh not really because honestly we're a
global company so i don't really worry
about
you know individual areas or regions i'd
say as a global company
we really try to embody that same
empathy and passion that i just
mentioned
earlier across every every region
from a personal standpoint that's the
stuff that fuels me
you know like i've been to companies
where i get dropped in at taco bell
in a month they have this uh you know
crisis and it's like a lawsuit
uh you know on their beef and then i get
to samsung and then uh
phones start catching on fire it's like
for me it's sort of par for the course
can we break the news here that maybe
you're no
even though you might be the hottest
prospect in all of marketing
you might also actually be a bad luck
charm should we firm that up here on
marketing for now like like
like you are starting to make me think
that you know like i'm always secretly
courting you to eventually work with you
but i'm like wait a minute something bad
might happen a week after
we get that deal done no it will happen
but it'll be the best thing for you
it'll be the best thing for any company
that i'm at because i i
love that on the shoulder you know i was
actually my number one question which
i've never asked you
is you really have had a skyrocketing
career like
like like i had so many people admire
you
in my circles before i got to really
know you who the hell is this kid
you know do you think it is the chip on
the shoulder like do you think it's
something from childhood is it the luck
of the draw of dna is there something
that you can pinpoint because i do think
i have a lot of
ambitious hungry characters watching
right now
that either may want to do it
entrepreneur while or may want to crush
it
you know corporate marketing wise and
they're learning a lot by watching me
and then have that leverage you know is
there is there some
insight to like if you know this is a
tough question why are you so awesome
but like
humbly to the best of your ability like
what is there an insight that can help
somebody who's watching now like why
this has happened
uh it's one of those things where you
you know i've talked about this over
dinner before
and i've never tried to dissect like the
the path that i've had
um too closely but um you know we
we've talked about being you know uh
immigrant
having immigrant parents and like i
noticed that like my friends circle
without me realizing it every single one
of my close friends that were like
groomsmen in my wedding
they all are first generation uh you
know
americans so i think there there's a
little bit of that like you have to
hustle
and you have to always grind just to
like catch up to people who have been
here for generations and
have things established and all that
stuff and i think especially in today's
time
you're seeing that come to light in a
big way um both positive and both
negative
and i think chip on the shoulder is that
like i i don't want to ever
be told like this is where you fit or
this is how you should conform or this
is what it takes for you to be
successful it's just to like
you know act like you belong like i want
to actually prove that like it's not
about
acting like belong like we're actually
setting the foundation and the framework
for what should be
the case for the future nick something
we haven't talked about
um even privately is i thought
you were hacking culture in a very
significant way
with hulu even though some of the ways
you did it pissed me off
tom [ __ ] brady uh but you know you
were really you were
you in a very short period of time like
you know what for the there's a lot of
executives who are watching right now
who are going to get their next
marketing job
what what enabled you to do so many you
know
some of the the cash stuff like with the
athletes the brady thing which caused a
huge
furry there there's a lot what kind of
freedom
and what kind of actions as an executive
does one who's watching this right now
have to do to get the breathing room to
what should people look for to be i mean
that was just a lot of good output in a
short period of time and i was really
like what's the mix what's the makeup of
that it's
it's a it's a few things i think coming
into a situation where
people don't feel like they have
everything together is a good thing
like coming into a company when they're
sort of about to take off versus
they've already made it has been huge uh
for me
and also having leaders that kind of
come into the situation
knowing that i'm bringing a certain
thing to the table and they're embracing
that
and they're giving me that runway to do
it like kelly
at hulu basically um said you're not
just going to run brand you're going to
run brand and culture
and the reason why i'm doing that
purposely is because you are someone
that i think has a pulse on both and you
can actually weave
that in in a way that helps us um you
know really cement ourself and culture
so
i think i've always come to a place
where they
they didn't feel like they had it
together and always worked for a leader
that basically said
hear the keys you know go run with it
and then uh
let us know if you need any help and
support i mean even at the highest level
at hulu with randy uh
former ceo he was very open and willing
to take risks even from the first
campaign which we called better ruins
everything like the tagline was
we're about to ruin tv for you and this
is like a streaming company
saying that we're going to ruin tv for
you which was sort of like you know bold
and
really like uh taking the traditional
idea of tv and flipping on its head and
i think
having their support really helped me do
what i was able to do in a short amount
of time
what about your own behavior what's
really stood out during covet
my own behavior yeah like what are you
watching yeah
i don't watch things anymore i just
watched you just live on ebay
and just try to buy sports cards i know
you're like i see you laughing andre
this is real we have a disease
something very good happening andrea if
there's a substantial chance that
vaynermedia is going to turn into a
sports card store
that literally when we all come back amy
i'm sorry about this like when you come
back into the office
you're gonna be standing behind a glass
case trying to sell optic rookie cards
of patrick mahomes so
i i can't help it i don't know what to
do i'm just the bug is real nick
but on the flip side they're gonna
they're gonna make more money than
they've ever seen in their life
i'm literally gonna make more money in
sports cards this year that i made in
vaynermedia the last 10 years it's like
absurd
yes actually let's talk about that what
actually let's talk about that [ __ ] it
obviously i come to you early on because
i know you like sports culture
you know we we we haven't we've worked
together a little bit but not as much
based on like how
much we vibe complex con different
things we've introduced our friends to
each other
like let's just break this down because
you weren't around
and we didn't know each other when i was
going everybody in 2005 and six and
saying we need to put all our money into
facebook and twitter when social media
was not a thing
yeah 15 [ __ ] years ago please tell
the audience here when i call you the
first time and say nick
you need to spend all your money on
sports cards
what goes through your head you're a big
time innovator you see [ __ ]
i'm just i actually never fully heard
you articulate it like what what's that
initial like processes when you hear
something very left field
yeah i remember i remember the the time
moment
where was yeah tell me i don't remember
we were at a
restaurant having breakfast it was
called lunetta all day
it's on uh it's in santa monica and
we were having breakfast we were talking
about life
and and you know professional life and
all that stuff
remember now i remember you were talking
about yes i remember go ahead and then
you literally said
hey uh i have an idea that's gonna melt
your face that's like those are the
words you use and like no one says i'm
gonna have an idea that's gonna melt
your face so i was like okay
you have my attention that's like the
hook uh you gotta deliver now like what
is this thing he's like it's an
investment
idea that's gonna literally melt your
face and i was like okay okay i'm ready
and i thought it was gonna be some like
new social platform or some new thing
that was like in
in the worlds that we live in and you're
like basketball cards
i'm just like what about basketball
cards you're like we're i'm buying
basketball cards and i thought you had
some source i was like
where are you buying passports ebay
are you selling these basketball cards
ebay wait wait hold on hold on
so you're buying basketball cards on a
public marketplace to sell them on that
same public marketplace
and you're telling me that's like a good
investment and you're like
absolutely so like i dipped my toe in
the water
and everything that you said to to buy
at the time like
you know it's it's it's like gone up 15x
or something disgusting in one year
15 absurd and then and then we got
hooked on stockx because at the time
uh stockx hadn't had trading cards they
just did sneakers and streetwear
and then that second that uh that team
josh and team like
brought trading cards into the mix it
was just like floodgates did you know
that that was an important inflection
point like you were like okay that's
interesting
i mean stockx is uh this
you know basically culture and i don't
mean like the second you know market for
like they're literally able to drive
what's what's hot to
to youth and i feel like by them getting
into collection
what's the learning in there as somebody
who's so tapped in
what's the insight or what can people
like what do you tell people
as being somebody who really sees things
when you hear something crazy like that
like
actually like if somebody said what did
after this scene
somebody hit you up and come to me like
what did you learn from that like what
what can
somebody who's watching because
obviously it's a funny story and people
like but for you
like when you like you're so young like
what happens the next time you hear
something like that like how are you
going to play that dip like do you judge
the j like i'm a big fan of judge the
judger the thing that pissed me off with
all my friends that they moved like
you remember you've been giving me
accolades for 15 years of always being
right about stuff
why was this one so hard to fathom like
i'm trying to figure out what
you know and much just telling a story
here for thousands that are watching
what's the thing to learn is it do real
homework when you hear something
is it never say no and say yes try a
little like what what's the
what's something i think you just gotta
think about the source kind of what you
just said about judging the judger like
it no no one person has their
pulse on culture at all times across all
things it's just not possible right so
you get a few people that you trust
because they have their pulse on new
music or they have their pulse on
new trends or the other pulse on
whatever and if you just sort of lean in
and
you accept the fact that they might see
something ahead of the time or they
might have
awareness to something before you do um
you just start to
experiment and then lean in and then
once you realize it's it's the thing you
you go in heavy
and that's the exact knowledge of the
sports cards like you said it i did a
bit
i realized i should have done a lot more
but it's all good because now i have
time to make up for it and it's fine
what uh what are you most well i'm blown
away by tic tocs innovation of product
speed i'm actually pumped to tic tocs on
the scene
because it's making another platform i
like a lot of competitors instagram
i think they're i can feel it that
they're being forced to innovate
because how fast you're innovating have
you you know you've been in a lot of
places
is my observation right is the speed of
innovation pretty remarkable
the speed at tick tock is incredible i
think it's a
it's it's a two-year-old company but we
we're starting to behave more like a
ten-year-old brand we're up leveling our
game in terms of the product the new
features the way that we
bring new things to market what we're
testing and innovating and ultimately
like how we're going to bring the market
to life
it'll it won't feel like a two-year-old
company which i think is the most
exciting part of what i'm doing
last 30 seconds anything people should
be thinking about or any value problem
uh i mean it's a place to have fun like
i'd say like most people
you hear all the news and you hear all
the press and at the end of the day
like this is truly a community where
people want to express themselves
creatively and they want to bring joy to
others
and you're on the platform and you
obviously obviously been advocating for
a while like
all the stuff that you see you leave the
platform after you've looked at it for
however long
and you feel like good yeah you're
smiling whereas like i'm on other
platforms sometimes
like no no knock on them like i'm
anxious when i go on twitter now
exactly exactly i'm never anxious so i'm
like it's heavy in there
it's heavy but like this is a this is
almost like the the nice
happy corner of the internet that people
are just starting to find and realizing
that it's actually impacting culture at
scale and
i think that's that's what i enjoy about
it like it's really a fun place to be
i love it nick thank you so much man i
wish you continued success
thank you hey everybody on youtube first
of all thank you so much so humbled for
your time
i don't want to watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from
feel free to check it out